i wanted to congratulate you too 20-year
wedding anniversary with your sweet
husband now
has howard stern paid up on the bet yet
no and there's a lot of charities that
would like that money howard so i'm just
saying i want to make a written bet with
you now in about 10 years you're going
to hunt me down and go howard i owe you
money
we'll do a written bet
put your money with your mouth i'll do
it right now but we have a million
dollars how many years before you say
you're only
no another anniversary coming up too 25
years since the very first movie that
you met your sweet husband on what do
you remember most about that movie i
didn't even know that someone told me
that today that it's 25 years
just remember the excitement about doing
something so different and it was my
first like real
location by myself and just everything
felt new and exciting and
i made lifelong friends so and are you
forever indebted to that film too
because of how it has played out for
your love life i mean it did okay for me
i love it congratulations on everything
personally and professionally i love
seeing your life play out and just oh
it's so sweet i have no complaints
today you let your anger control you
from now on i want you
to control it
channel that anger into getting what you
want
our headmaster herself how much fun did
you have with this role it was the
ultimate i mean jen really just let me
run with it and we created it from
scratch and it was just delicious i
think is the only word although i do
feel that i it needs a quote at the
bottom that lots of bonsais were hurt
in the filming of this movie how did you
feel the nostalgia that we all felt as
an audience member
i think i felt the nostalgia but i also
felt the excitement about sort of the
reincarnation of these kinds of movies
because you're never you never grow out
of these like this is just the ultimate
fun ride
now it's so funny because every person
that i talk to gushes over being able to
have worked with you on this film would
you be down to reprise the role in a
sequel
the sequel the headmaster coming to
netflix next year
honestly this group was so much fun and
i had so much to learn from all of them
and jen i mean if jen called me tomorrow
to read the phone book i would do it
i love that now i wanted to ask you your
sweet friend selma is gonna be on
dancing with the stars how excited are
you i'm i'm excited i think my daughter
takes the cake is the most excited she
almost gave up her own 13th birthday to
be there for open for i guess you don't
call it opening night for her first
performance so i said no you don't give
up that's a once in a lifetime thing you
have your 13th birthday we'll go later
so you and your daughter will be in the
stands cheering so much yes i'm actually
amanda and i need to figure out when we
can all make it together i love that so
much that's so special i do i love your
guys friendship so much
[Music]